vielen Dank danke ja liebe Gäste dann darf
ich euch mal herzlich willkommen heißen zu
dieser besonderen Betriebsweihnachtsfeier
der Anstalt also wie immer dabei jedes Jahr
ne und was werden wir ohne sie die Satire
und die Moral abd ich glaube sie haben zwei
erwachsen als Moral undstiere verkleidet sind
so wild Bruder ganz besonders freue ich mich
heßen Schapira und Abdul Schahin ja wir haben hier
mit sch ein Standup komedien geboren in Israel
und Abdul wir haben hier jemanden ein Standup
Comedian geboren in Siegburg bei Bonn liegt das
in Palästina dessen palästinensische Eltern einst
aus dem Libanon nach Deutschland geflohen kam und
sie beide feiern heute während hanoka zusammen
mit zwei bayerischen Christen ich bin Atheist
ja okay also mit einem bayerischen Christen und
einem Spielverderber ich bin Agnostiker Agnostiker
also mit zwei spielverderbern feiern wir heute
friedvoll die Geburt eines Juden namens Jesus
geboren in Bethlehem im Westjordanland das wie
wir alle wissen zur Zone a der palästinensischen
Autonomie Gebiete gehört Maria und Josef als
Juden hätten dort keinen Zutritt und na ja
natürlich auch die arabischen Christen die
hätten Schwierigkeiten an den israelischen
Checkpoints und so wünsche
ich uns allen friedvolle
Weihnachten okay also damit ich richtig verstehe
wir haben Palästinenser und ein Israeli eingeladen
um eine friedvolle Weihnachtssendung zu haben
ja Hauptsache es gibt was zu Essen zu dem
Berufe habe ich extra hum anfertigen lassen
weil das ist ja euer Nationalgericht ne und
oh mach das zu es riecht nach Antisemitismus
das ist kein Humus Hus humomus Humus Humus
du unkulier sorry sorry es geht noch ein
Dönerladen um die Ecke ich bin Palästinenser
warum sollte ich Döner Schaf mit ohne Salat
bitte ja aber ist denn so ein Döner überhaupt
koscher ist deine Mutter koscher das WE ich bin
der Agnostiker W soll ich das wissen ja her von
Wagner das mit den friedvollen Weihnachten läuft
gut bis jetzt oder Moral wie seid ihr denn seid
ihr denn gut hergekommen jao das denn ich bin
do ständig hier du insbondere ein bisschen zu
häufig in letzter Zeit was willst denn damit sagen
Satire bitte ohne deine Moralpredigten hätten wir
längst eine Primetime Sendung im Privatfernsehen
ohne mich wärst du einfach nur ein zynisches
Arschloch ein Arschloch aber mit ausverkauft
auf der Olympiahalle also an die Erfolge an die
Erfolge die ich mit Astrid linkring gefeiert habe
musst du erstmal rankommen Herr von Wagner wollte
friedvolle Weihnachten ja oh Verzeihung ja wenn
sich jemand einen friedlichen Abend ohne Kinder
oder sonstige Verpflichtungen verdient hat dann
natürlich mitteleuropäische weiße Männer gehobenen
Alters die mal dich damit erstens ich bin nicht
so alt wie die du Schmock und zweitens sind wir
vollzillig kommen noch mehr kostümhe was machen
wir hier ich denke ihr seid aus demselben Grund
hier wie wir weil diese beiden Humor Steller sich
alleine nicht trauen über den nostkonflikt zu
reden das kann man so nicht sagen der Herr utof
und ich wir haben lediglich Angst alleine über
den nausonf also gut also sehen Sie in diesen
Zeiten während also der Krieg auch noch das da
ist ein bisschen was zu sagen ist natürlich
doof aber gar nichts zu sagen ist noch viel
doofer aber das was man sagt ist dann natürlich
doof ich habe me Freundin Meli kiak geschrieben
dass wir eine Sendung zum narostkrieg machen oh
was hat du geantwortet mach's gut alter Freund
Leute reiß euch mal zusammen es ist doch euer Job
euer Job ist es doch das Elend dieses Planeten in
halbwegs brauchbare poanten umzuwandeln und wie
sagte Volker pispas immer wenn man weiß wo der
Feind sitzt hat der tach Struktur als deutsche
Kabarettisten wisst ihr doch morgens kurz nach
dem Aufstehen wer oder was der Feind ist egal
ob gesetzeswiedrier Haushaltsführung od oder
blockierte Verkehrswende komm wir sagen es doch
einmal gemeinsam schuld ist immer die FDP ja fein
ja jetzt kann man der FDP einiges vorwerfen
aber nicht dass sie aus dem gaserstreifen mit
Gleitschirm nach Israel zum Morden geflogen
ist und da Hamers ja schon das Problem wenn
es die FDP nicht gewesen sein kann seid ihr
Kabarettisten ja völlig überfordert maximal
irritiert wenn sowas Blödes passiert was bauen wir
dann noch flott in den Text ein einen nazergleich
obach bei nazergleichen nicht alles was hingt
ist ein Göbbels zurück zum naoskonflikt nein
zum Krieg gegen die Hamas nein zum zur legitimen
Selbstverteidigung des Staates Israel zum Terror
im Heiligen Land da geht's ja schon los ihr
wisst ja nicht mal wie ihr es nennen sollt klar
Bezeichnung ist ja automatisch eine Positionierung
ich würde mich spontan eher auf die jüdische Seite
schlagen aus beruflichen Gründen weil es Kabarett
seit Jahrzehnten kaum muslimisches Publikum
hat nostkonflikt was ist das für ein Begriff
nostkonflikt es könnte auch ein parteiinterner
Streit in der thüringischen AFD sein auf der
anderen Seite fragwürdige kollektivbestrafung
antisemitischer Moslem Nazis ist jetzt auch
kein ganz neutrales Etikett und dann auch der
ganze Ärger mit der Recherche ganz verzichten
würde ich auf so ein Scheiß wie Internet ganz
ehrlich sie haben doch keine Ahnung von
den Quellen häufig hat man doch so eine
Kinderleiche längst gepostet Wochen bevor jemand
merkt dass dieses Foto zweieinhalb Jahrzehnte
alt und noch aus dem Kosovokrieg übrig war
glücklicherweise kommt man beim nordostkonflikt
Entschuldigung bei der militärischen
sonderoperation zur Existenzsicherung des
gelobten Landes man kommt auch ganz gut durch mit
Allgemeinplätzen ja Israel ist ja die einzige e
Demokratie in der Region ja toll Bielefeld ist
auch die einzige echte Großstadt in Ostwestfalen
Lippe und jetzt oh du die israel hat ja die Hamas
selbst erst groß gemacht damals im Kampf gegen die
fatach ja shit happens die Union pusht ja auch die
AFD um die Grünen zu bekämpfen es ist ein tolles
Konzept gut vielleicht müssen wir alle mal wieder
ganz in Ruhe in unserem guten alten tucholski
nachschen doch doch da steht doch mehr drin als
nur dieses was darf die Satire z.B eine Satire
die zur Zeichnung einer kriegsanlei auffordert
ist keine Kriegsanleihe Zeichen ich musste das
auch erstmal googelen im Brockhaus also Satire die
zur Unterstützung für irgendeinen Krieg aufruft
ist keine Satire wenn das stimmt dann läuft seit
Beginn des ukrainekriegs sehr wenig Kabarett im
Fernsehen machen Sie es einfach wie Menschen
die ihr Geld auf telegram verdienen stellen
sie immer suggestiv fragen sie gucken einfach so
bedeutungsschwanger in die Kamera das kriegen sie
doch hin sie gucken da so rein und sagen sowas wie
so so entlang der am besten gesicherten Grenze der
Welt dauert es über 7 Stunden um zu reagieren
auf einen Angriff mit Paraglidern und mppets
ja ich weiß wenn man nur irgendwie rausfinden
könnte dass doch die FDP ihre Finger im Spiel
hatte dann wäre wenigstens die Welt im deutschen
Kabarett wieder in Ordnung groß fest also das ist
do
hat schon Christian Linder hat schon Christian
Linder gesagt lieber gar nicht reagieren als
falsch war das jetzt schon der Sketch zur
fehlenden Anteilnahme der deutschen nach
dem Massaker der Hamas am 7 Oktober mein nach JAL
habt ihr doch auch reagiert ja gut gut Paris nzza
wer von uns war da noch nicht als terrorourist
wie sollen wir das denn machen wie soll wir das
denn verarbeiten angemessen satirisch diese
diese brutalen goldatten 7 Oktober wie soll
man das das das das machen goldaten die nur
Entsetzen und Mitleid ausgelöst haben und das
Ganze am Ende auch noch mit Herrn utoff also
sie stellen sich aber auch immer an ist do
nicht so schwer ganz einfach stellt sich hin und
dann sagt man also wo wo also wer ich hab's ich
hab's was macht eigentlich Volker wising oh
Gott Gott Gott das ist do das kann nicht das
ist eben sehen Sie das ist kein s für Satire
das ist viel zu schwierig das ist alles das
Satire brauchen klaren Gegner ein klaren Gegner
und die Hamas ist ihn als Gegner jetzt eher zu
verschwommen das wo wollen sie denn hin sie no
sitzen wir brauchen sie nämlich ja ja was was
wollen die von uns Bruder ich weiß es nicht ich
glaube sie wollen dass wir ih den naus Konflikt
erklären ach so ach wir sind hier weil ihr unsere
Perspektive zum nauskonflikt hören möchte wenn das
ginge
okay darf ich frageno wonach sie suchen nach
Ahmed Mansur es ist nämlich gesetzlich verboten
im öffentlichrechtlichen über den auskonflikt zu
sprechen ohne dass er eingeladen ist echt nicht
ja echt okay nehmen wir mal an ja wir würden
euch helfen eine Sendung zu machen zu Israel
und Palästina mit uns und mit euch und hier
mit Anstand und eurem komischen Sex Clown wie
wird es aussehen pass auf Anfang der Sendung wir
lassen Abdul Abdul kommt auf so einem Gleitschirm
ins Studio geflogen das nur eine erste Idee auf
gar keinen Fall erzähl mir mehr oder oder durch
ein tuddel das W nein nein vielleicht beten
wir im Hinterkopf oder wir lassen schahak mit
einer Kipper durch Neuköln nein erzähl mir mehr
das sind alles furchtbare Ideen mein Gott dann
mache ich halt einfach eine Impro ja ich stell
mich hin und sage ich verneine das Existenzrecht
Gott der hab okay sie können h nicht einfach
mit stillehgreif Arbeiten nicht bei dem das
ma ich do immer so aber nicht bei dem Thema
da braucht man Recherche Recherche Recherche
ganz viel fingerspitzengfühl müssen wir uns
denn unbedingt bei diesem Thema die Finger
verbrennen ich will doch einfach nur das was
jeder Künstler will verstehen Sie den Finger
tief in die Hunde der Gesellschaft legen bis es
richtig weh tut und dann am Ende von allen geliebt
werden okay okay okay gut dann
dann also dieses Thema also hier
sati Moral auf geht Brainstorming was
her von was ma ich denn sie machen das
was sie am besten könen alles klar
aber Moment das Warin Depot hat doch
zu so Herr haben sie abonniert Glocke gedrückt was
sich eines von den beiden Videos hier angeschaut
h sie es reicht mir vollkommen dass ich in den
meisten mitspielen muss glauben Sie dass es die
richtige Art ist für uns Werbung zu machen werde
ich dafür bezahlt nee was zum Henker mache ich
dann hier er ist sonst nicht so sie können sich
ja in der Zwischenzeit was ohne ihn anschauen